non ho sentito la mia presentazione
prima quindi non so se ha detto cose
giuste io spero di sì dopo cercherò di
sentire allora
buongiorno a tutti io mi chiamo federico
baglioni sono milanese trapiantato a
roma e sono un biotecnologo quindi
principalmente come il biotecnologo il
mio la mia aspirazione qualche anno fa
almeno fino a qualche anno fa era quello
di fare ricerca
certo punto per una serie di motivi ho
deciso di cambiare sono evitato un
divulgatore scientifico come mine di
google tra re scientifico perché un po
perché probabilmente non era l'ambiente
di laboratorio non era esattamente il
mio ambiente poi mi piaceva parlare alle
persone spiegare la scienza spiegare
quello che fanno i ricercatori
come mai come mai perché la scienza non
è facile da capire anzi generalmente ne
capiamo abbastanza poco e quindi io
vorrei parlare proprio di questo è
andare un pochino più del front del
profondo cioè come mai
facciamo fatica a capire per esempio la
scienza e facciamo un passo ancora
indietro
tutto nasce nel nostro cervello c'è il
nostro cervello fa delle 16 delle
cappellate sbaglia e vi faccio subito
con partendo con un esempio in
particolare un test che questo qui cosa
dovete fare
chi ha già visto muti mi raccomando eh e
cosa dovete fare dovete contare il
numero di passaggi della squadra bianca
solo della squadra bianca pronti
ok benissimo
ok quanti passaggi 21 come 21
ok 16 21 altre proposte che offre di più
allora la risposta giusta lo controllato
stanotte perché non ero molto convinto
sono sedici quanti hanno visto il
gorilla il gorilla di registro e fuori
di melone c'è un gorilla
ok non solo allora dico però tensione
che è che l'aveva già visto e furgoni
ok oltre al gorilla sono successe delle
altre cose in realtà è sparito una
persona se n'è andata via dal palco e
nel frattempo lo sfondo ha cambiato
colore quanti avevano visto anche queste
due cose una persona una a nessuno aveva
visto queste cose molto poco
generalmente cos'è che è successo è
successo che noi abbiamo prestato
attenzione a qualche cosa chi ha la
palla
chi magari era un po distratto ha
iniziato a contare poi perso il conto si
è messo a guardare in giro e quindi
magari ha visto gorilla anche quello chi
aveva già visto al gorilla era lì agli
altri non sanno cosa vis cosa ho visto
io se messa deve guardare in giro magari
ha visto la persona che è uscita e via
dicendo
a questo punto cosa serve questo questo
test proprio a mandarvi un messaggio
cioè il nostro cervello bello
affascinante tremendamente affascinante
complicato fa un sacco di cose belle e
positive però non è perfetto siamo
portati a pensare che sia una macchina è
tutto l'opposto anche il nostro cervello
sbaglia e in particolare sbaglia quando
quando ci sono di mezzo alle emozioni
quando c'è di mezzo il cuore le emozioni
sono una cosa che ci pervade siamo fatti
per essere suggestionati siamo fatti
anche per emozionarci che è una cosa
bellissima
però a volte non ci fa più ragionare un
esempio particolare è quando si ha a che
fare con la scienza perché la scienza
perché la scienza è complicata e abbiamo
questo dualismo cioè vediamo i
ricercatori da un lato come i
raggiungere
d come delle persone magnifiche della
specie di super eroi che fanno cose
strane nei laboratori
dall'altra parte però abbiamo anche un
po paura di loro abbiamo paura di quello
che possono fare della loro potenza
e tutto questo crea un vero e proprio
cortocircuito in particolare noi abbiamo
quindi paura un pochino della scienza ve
lo dimostro questa è un'immagine di cosa
c'è nel mixer a lamela e mcdonald allora
io vi chiedo
guardando queste immagini prendereste
mai un prodotto del genere
lo dice che me frega tanto ho sempre
preso così non è che mi cambi molto
oppure se non lo prendevo prime non
prova neanche adesso cos'è che vi
spaventa e piena di cose che i perché
che cosa sono queste cose
ve lo dico io cosa sono sono i composti
di una qualsiasi mela qualsiasi e pro
inventato io ho preso sapendo cosa c'è
dentro la mela ci sono questi composti
tanto brutti e io ho messo un immagine
nera che nera fa un po sempre paura
incute timore ho utilizzato un po il
simbolo della multinazionale cattiva via
dicendo e oh trasmesso un messaggio di
paura associato delle parole che non
conoscete che non conoscono anch'io gran
parte e che appunto non so che
tendenzialmente mi fanno paura sia
perché non le conosco sia perché sono
parole chimiche noi abbiamo una paura
incredibile della chimica a volte anche
per motivi storici incidenti del passato
in generale noi a quando sentiamo
qualcosa legato alla chimica diciamo
questa cosa sarà una cosa dannosa
a prescindere si chiama proprio kimo
fobia paura delle parole chimiche questo
è un altro esempio che si può trovare su
internet digitando si vede questo ashley
dri con queste caratteristiche
brutte brutte produzioni erosione del
suolo piogge acide presenti nei tumori
ce l'ha praticamente tutte l'acido
idrico di h m osta per monossido di
diidrogeno non so se vi ricordate
lezioni di chimica
monossido vuole dire che c'è un ossigeno
di idrogeno volete che ci sono due
idrogeno 2 idrogeno ossigeno
chiamasi anche acqua ok perfetto tutto
bene lo dice ma perché mi stai dicendo
questa cosa per due motivi uno perché
qualcuno ci ha fatto addirittura una
petizione per bloccare la molecola e c'è
qualcuno che ha firmato
inconsapevolmente perché a firma perché
uno dovrebbe firmare una cosa del genere
perché ci sono delle parole chiave
parole chiave che ci incutono timore
tumori ustioni per già ce ne sono gran
parte dei problemi della società che
vediamo e quindi non ci interessa più
sapere esattamente di cosa si stia
parlando ci va bene bloccarla perché una
cosa che va contro le nostre paure e in
altre parole noi siamo il nostro
cervello è fatto per semplificare deve
essere tutto rossonero bianconero se
sette juventini e in generale vediamo
delle associazioni anche dove non ci
sono due eventi per noi sono legati tra
loro perché ci sembra logico è quella la
cosa incredibile che a noi sembra
assolutamente logico e non è detto che
sia così
vi faccio un esempio con un altro video
che ci vuole l'audio
no
ok allora facciamo un po ripas cosa è
successo l'avete capito vero sì ok il
bambino che cosa sta facendo sta usando
no non i superpoteri ragazzi la forza le
basi è la forza ok lo sta usando la
forza per accendere la macchina
ok crede di usare la forza e così poi
sono i due eventi
in realtà chi è che accende la macchina
il padre tutti convinti vero se ok la
accende il padre allora in questo caso
ne abbiamo due eventi che ci sembrano
legati al bambino sembrano sembra logico
che lui fa così accende la macchina in
realtà c'è un terzo evento che quello di
causa ok allora in questo caso è molto
semplice ma pensate quanto può essere
complicato quando si ha a che fare con
la salute l'alimentazione pure appunto
malattie e via dicendo mi diventa molto
complesso ragionare in termini razionali
e vedere vedere che magari non ci sono
relazioni tra due eventi magari c'è una
terza causa diventa veramente complicato
allora che cosa possiamo imparare un
pochino da questi piccoli piccole cose è
appunto il nostro cervello è si fa
ingannare quindi dobbiamo un pochino
starci sempre attenti perché le ci
vediamo spinti dalle emozioni che sono
una cosa che ci fanno fare tante cose
molto utili che è anche di sopravvivenza
a volte però ci ci mettono nei guai per
cui ci fanno a credere a cose che non
sono vere e la scienza ha un problema
particolare che purtroppo la scienza
tante cose solo in un modo quindi
bisogna attenersi a quelli che sono i
fatti e non a quello che crediamo noi
per esempio è quello è un grosso
problema grosso problema anche perché
ormai da decenni si usa tantissimo
internet su internet può scrivere
chiunque e quindi questo qui aumenta
questa difficoltà pensate se voi andate
a cercare su google non so il virus
virus della malaria
trovate il virus della malaria però la
malaria non è un virus se cercate bene
trovate anche dimostrazioni che la terra
è piatta
il genere vi assicuro potete trovare
veramente tante cose perché il google è
fatto per confermare i nostri pregiudizi
i nostri pensieri e noi non piace mai
sentirci scemi non ci piace quindi
andiamo su internet e cerchiamo la
nostra risposta e su internet vi
assicuro la nostra risposta la troviamo
sempre quindi come fare ad esempio
nell'ambito scientifico salute è
sicuramente complicato però ci sono dei
piccoli e strategie
innanzitutto individuare quando ci sono
quelle parole chiave anche fatto vedere
prima quando ci sono queste parole
chiave vending lampadina attenzione
forse siamo siamo più deboli
in quel momento dobbiamo farci
attenzione come facciamo capirlo
possiamo affidarci a delle altre persone
altre persone che siano competenti nel
campo della scienza della salute non
affidiamoci al primo che passa non
affidiamoci a chi magari chi ci vende
qualcosa di nuovo che ci sembra logico
perché a volte purtroppo la scienza
funziona in maniera diversa
affidiamoci a persone competenti ci sono
tante scienziati ricercatori e che
parlano in maniera corretta di temi come
alimentazione salute via dicendo
cerchiamo di affidare loro ci sono
pagine scientifiche le scienze oggi
scienza italianità per la scienza ce ne
sono tante che potete consultare un po
come tipo vicino quando quando si hanno
dei dubbi perché tutti noi abbiamo dei
dubbi
come mai il bicchiere d'acqua non perché
voglio evitare che vi gatte l'acqua anzi
bevetela è una cosa che fa bene ma per
dirvi continuate a cercare a
incuriosirvi perché è una cosa che è
bellissima il nostro cervello nostro
cuore è giusto che lo fa che lo facciano
perché una cosa che ci da tantissime
soddisfazioni
facciamo sempre attenzione a a chi sa
chi diamo la nostra fiducia e
possibilmente cerchiamo di non perderci
in un bicchiere d'acqua razzi